okay Trump care is back sort of kind of
there's a new proposal again that would
include the repeal of the Affordable
Care Act Obamacare it would put in place
something else this was a major campaign
promise for Donald Trump total failure
to execute so far right I mean
embarrassing defeat after defeat on the
repeal and replacement of the Affordable
Care Act for Donald Trump and I want to
go through this new proposal with you in
detail this new proposal is from two
Republican senators Lindsey Graham and
Bill Cassidy previously the Trump care
proposals are Republic hair the American
health care act whatever you want to
call it estimates said that somewhere
between 22 and 24 million people would
end up without health care as a result
of the repeal and replacement of Obama
care compared to the status quo within
the decade following the passage of
these different fortunately failed
replacement bills this new bill which is
the Graham Cassidy bill could be even
worse so let's start by looking at the
provisions of this new Trump care bill
number one Graham Cassidy would end the
Obama care tax credits for middle-income
Americans absolute disaster number two
Graham Cassidy would end certain
subsidies for lower income Americans the
new Trump care would end Medicaid
expansions in a variety of states that
would affect 11 million adults it would
add block grants which would be smaller
amounts than the money that's been taken
away that would be taken away and those
Block Grants would expire completely in
2027 which creates a total cliff
situation it would cut coverage for
low-income seniors children and disabled
people it would end protections on
pre-existing conditions lifetime caps
and essential benefits it would also
make it so that states receiving the
grant money can waive certain federal
laws that protect consumers or buyers of
health insurance and lastly and and very
immorally it would allow insurance
companies to charge higher premiums to
people that are sick even if they
becomes
sic after purchasing insurance it's no
longer insurance when you do that
insurance works by averaging the risk
across many buyers and of course
mathematically right the more buyers the
better so that no one person has to be
price gouged but everybody can be
covered and have predictable medical
expenses as their need to use those
services might increase as can happen
when you get sick as can happen when you
age if you think well listen David I
don't care about this and most people
don't have to worry because most people
have employer health care not true it's
a sort of complex but it relates to the
lifetime caps and pre-existing
conditions and some other elements but
check out the Brookings Institute
explanation of how this new plan could
affect even people who have employer
health care what will the net effect of
this proposed plan be well according to
Andy Slavitt who is the he actually ran
the Centers for Medicare and Medicaid
Services under President Obama he
estimates that this plan would see not
22 million not 24 million not 26 or 28
or 30 million but 32 million people end
up without health care 32 million people
that currently have health care now
you'll notice in that number
it's worse than a straight Obamacare
repeal right that means that the new
provisions of this plan above and beyond
the repeal of the Affordable Care Act
will actually kick even more people off
of health insurance and if you read
through the list with me of the
provisions just a couple of minutes ago
you would understand why it allows for
price gouging for example it allows for
the you're already talking about the
waiver of Medicaid at many many in in
many many states and this isn't just a
punishment for getting sick this is sort
of an encouragement to health insurance
companies to make health care as
unaffordable as possible as soon as
people get sick this is a major profit
and price gouging boon for health
insurance company
the Center for Budget and Policy
Priorities says that this new plan the
Graham Cassidy plan would quote gut
protections for people with pre-existing
conditions impose damaging cuts to
Medicaid and caused many millions of
people to lose coverage this would be
virtually identical to a repeal without
replacement bill except for the
additional freedom that it would give
health insurance companies now Mitch
McConnell has asked for this to be
fast-tracked by the CBO the CBO is the
nonpartisan Congressional Budget Office
we're hoping that by early next week
we would have a scoring from the CBO to
know is 32 million accurate is it not
that would be maybe on the 25th or 26th
of the month they want to vote on this
by September 30th no time has been
allocated for actual debate once again
it was the Republicans in 2010 who
wanted debate before Obamacare has
passed and now they are providing no
time for debate before they vote on this
abortion of a bill right you're talking
about a fifth of the economy it would be
nice if they could bring it to some
committees may be getting some
Democratic input on it at least maybe
when it goes to the house I mean they're
just going to have to sign off on the
same bill they can't draft their own and
come with a consolidation process and go
to the next one there's no time for
anything and it by design right and and
when we think about well could this pass
Senator Pat Roberts of Kansas is quoted
as saying they are one vote away now you
might say we hear one vote away what
happened to all of those Republicans who
seem to understand why this is a
disaster they are trying to ram this
through by September 30th which is the
last day that Republicans can pass
legislation related to the budget with a
simple majority meaning 50% plus one
after September 30th Republicans would
need 60 votes to pass this and that's
not going to happen yeah and I don't
understand how there's so much closer
now he says it's only one vote away
because Murkowski and Collins oppose the
passed Obamacare repeal efforts because
it would have ended the Medicaid
expansion this would as well and john
mccain said that he may go on board if
the arizona governor signed off on AI
her
that for me I don't think he's going to
do it listen this is it's it's a they're
presenting themselves as being one vote
away to make it seem like this has more
support no when you only need fifty one
votes instead of sixty you're instantly
nine votes closer without actually
having convinced anybody and we are
really at a critical moment in American
history when it comes to health
insurance we have an employer connected
for-profit health insurance system
that's not working right we spend more
on health care per capita than even
really high cost of living countries
like Luxembourg and Switzerland we have
this thing called medical expense caused
bankruptcies that are unimaginable in
many other developed countries we have
Obamacare now if everybody who supported
a for-profit health insurance didn't try
to sabotage Obamacare I've talked about
this before you could actually have
Obamacare work pretty well it wouldn't
upend the system and you would have
something that is supported by all and
then Republicans could keep their
for-profit insurance plans you wouldn't
see Bernie Sanders talking about
Medicare for all with such support
because we would have full support for
Obamacare now we have a proposal from
Bernie Sanders to expand Medicare to
cover everybody paid for through attacks
that the average family would pay about
thirteen hundred dollars a year for much
less than they pay for health insurance
currently but it would be bad for health
insurance companies that industry would
suffer people would lose their jobs who
work within the health insurance
industry there would be pain associated
with that but it would be really good in
terms of coverage and then we have these
Republican plans which have threatened
to leave anywhere from twenty to twenty
three twenty four now possibly thirty
two million people without coverage
people who now have it this is not a
small moment for the United States on
this issue it represents some major real
philosophical differences about how life
should be organized do we see health
care as a for-profit product like any
other that works well in a free market
if you can't afford health care do you
consider that to be like not being able
to afford a new fancy car or a new
iPhone
if that's your worldview that healthcare
is just another product that some people
can afford and some can't that gets you
the system we have employer connected
for-profit health insurance medical
bankruptcies price gouging the other
view is that you see health care is a
basic right that should be afforded to
everyone regardless of ability to pay
not just for moral reasons not just
because the demand for health care is
not a market free market demand curve
but because you realize everybody's
better off when we all have access not
only to health insurance but actual
health care it's good financially it's
good for hospitals it's good from a
crime perspective and this is the battle
right now
it's about more than just whether or not
we shut down Obama cares healthcare.gov
or end the individual mandate people
will die under these Republican
proposals according to Harvard 45,000
American's die every year already from
lack of health coverage and that those
numbers are eight years old from 2009
what will the new number me be it's it's
more than a 911 every month people dying
from lack of health care and we saw in
the previous versions of the Republican
Obamacare repeal efforts maybe twenty
million people would lose coverage 21 22
now it's up to 30 so I'd imagine that
that Harvard study of 45,000 people
dying every year would have to be
revisited at exorbitant oh it would be
higher there's no way it's going to be
lower and this is why I'm wondering if
something even more sinister is going on
here because it appears that with each
new version of Trump Care it's even more
depraved it's even more immoral it's
almost like Republicans are taking
vengeance on the previous versions
getting shut down and you mentioned this
earlier Pat will maverick hero John
McCain vote for this one will people
still be singing his praises on
September 30th I'm not sure Lindsey
Graham is his best buddy in the Senate
Lindsey Graham's mere involvement in
this proposal already is making me
question whether John McCain can be
counted on to be the right thing and I
was just thinking yesterday preparing
for the story I just can't imagine
loving money so much that I'd rather
endless tens or
hundreds of thousands of people died
then save a few percentage points of
profit for this or that health insurance
company but then I reread this very
interesting article in the Scientific
American about how psychologists paul
piff and dr. Keltner they ran a bunch of
studies looking at whether social class
influences how much you care about the
feelings and circumstances of others and
it makes a huge difference when you
achieve wealth and status you
significantly experience fewer feelings
of compassion for others wealth makes us
worse at recognizing the emotions of
other people and that may be a factor
here remember those Obamacare death
panels that didn't actually exist it's
coming full circle it's coming full
circle it's time to call your elected
officials look them up at who is my
representative calm I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman and we'll keep talking about this
there the video you just finished
watching was made possible by you
through the membership program you can
sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership